it's being called the end of an era as
AMC's hit TV series Mad Men begins its
seventh and final season next month over
eight years the drama has earned three
Golden Globe Awards for Best television
show cast member January Jones speaks
about the show and her character Betty
Francis formerly known as Betty Draper
when I signed on to do the show there
was nobody there was no character I mean
I Matt wrote a couple scenes for me to
audition it but after shooting the pilot
there was like a year in between not
knowing if we were gonna get picked up
or we were gonna even have a show and I
kind of had a verbal agreement or
handshake from Matt Winer that if the
show did go there would be a role for me
that he would delve into that part of
Don's life so I gambled and paid off do
you like the character that she's become
i've always liked her I've always feel
like I had to fend her a lot but I've
always liked her and I've always liked
her her humanity and her flaws and her
her search for happiness and I admire
her bravery and um I don't know she's
very dear to me I think I mean Abba
obviously never played a character so
long so I'm up I'm very attached but I
feel like when people have a reaction to
her that's negative it's because they
see themselves in her and it was just
very telling when someone has a positive
or negative reaction to her I find it
fascinating is there any similarity that
bravery is there any similarity between
that and the bravery of let's say
leaving a place like South Dakota and
coming to New York and having a whole
career that's different than what you
would do it I just think I was brave I
think I was stupid um I was young and I
was um had no fear I wouldn't do that
now I don't think hailey I don't know if
it was brave but I maybe it was um why
wouldn't you do it now moving such a
drag just the physical aspect I just
moved um I think I guess it was brave I
just didn't think of it that way as a
kid
I mean I was like three days after I
turn 18 and I was like going to New York
and gonna be a big star and it just
didn't occur to me that that wouldn't
happen and so it was either my naiveté
or my my fearlessness I guess that made
everything happen that has happened for
me and a lot of luck probably have you
been at all struck by the historical
differences between the character that
you play in the 60s and the current
roles that women get the play I think
that a lot of great things have happened
for a woman um since then I think that
we still have a long way to go I think
we put a lot of pressure on ourselves um
should have and do it all well and uh
but I think that for Betty she's doing
exactly what she wanted to do and she's
doing exactly what she was told she
should do she where the consequences I
think so I think that she is very um
educated and I think she's very
knowledgeable I mean Betty's only
character we ever see read anything that
has anything to do with the feminist
movement she reads The Feminine Mystique
by Betty Friedan she's only one that
does that and and yet we feel like she's
the most unempowered woman on the show
but she she's there's one episode where
she wants to rekindle her modeling
career and Don kind of puts the kibosh
on that and but there's there's no
reason why she couldn't have done it
when she married Henry Francis so I feel
like she's where she wants to be but for
there was a lot less opportunity than
especially educationally for women is
there a particular actor actress
director or someone that you wish was
still alive that you could have worked
with this or a favorite that you have
that you keep in the back of your mind I
would think maybe Marilyn Monroe she had
great comic timing I love she seems
funny